hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the semi-finals of the phoenix
grand prix uh 2022 currently being
played in berlin it's wesley so versus
amin tabatabai and uh we've seen what
happened in the classical section wesley
won the first game and then he was doing
great in the second game and then he
played that one move that allowed i mean
to take the win and it was really an
incredible one if you haven't seen it do
check it out uh we made a video on it
some three videos ago uh but now we are
in rapids and uh this is uh well another
very impressive game uh most often in
chess the the greatest part of a chess
game isn't actually played but we have
to see it during analysis and here i
prepared one such move uh you will be
extremely extremely impressed by it and
you will well really want to tell every
every everyone you know
about this great idea so let's dive
straight into it but before that uh just
a quick news uh
uh well in info basically on what is
happening with ding liran he is
currently on uh eight win eight points
out of nine so he won seven games uh in
the drew two games and he's doing very
well he's almost on two uh twenty eight
uh ten so he's some to twenty eight nine
rating
and he is uh doing extremely well uh if
he continues this he will be
well in time to qualify for the uh fide
candidates tournament so that being said
uh let's check out the game and see what
this is all about wesley has the white
pieces and he opens with d4
knight to f6 we have c for g6 knight to
c3 and the bishop to g7 we have the
king's indian defense on the board e4
and now d6 we have knight to f3 and
castle so this is all very standard
stuff nothing new happening here bishop
e2 knight b to d7 and we have castles
black strikes in the central with e5 as
black usually does in this line of the
kings indian uh bishop to e3 and now c6
white grabs more space in the center
plays d5 and now black closes the center
with a move like c5 we have knight to d2
and now usually knights the ea displayed
here you want to free up some room for
this pawn to be pushed to f5 but here we
have kink the h8 still not a new idea
and here bishop to g5 and a3 are the
moves that are usually played but here
uh wesley plays a move that has never
been played before and that is pawn to
g4 uh so as of movie 11 we have a
completely new game uh and it counters
black's uh
well uh most uh
usual idea against this line which is to
move the knight to
the e8 and strike here with f5 so this
kind of prevents this but not really
maybe it even encourages this uh who
knows but wesley prepared it and it's uh
it's up to i mean to to figure out what
to do here so he starts with knights to
g8 uh if you go knight to e8 now then uh
it's not as great white will just play
king to h1 and then uh for example if
you strike with f5 it might not be so
great we're gonna play g captures g
captures and now after e captures you
don't have this bishop to capture the uh
the rook you might have to capture with
the rook and then this is a funny
looking position the rook can come to g1
and not something maybe that you would
want to do so instead of going back with
the knight there after g4 we have knight
to g8 and now after knight to f3 we have
knight to b6 so now we clear this room
uh for the bishop now bishop controls
the f5 square and we are preparing f5 so
h3 by wesley as the g4 pawn was also
attacked and now pawn to f5 we have g
characters g captures e captures and now
the shop captures an f5 we have knights
to g5 by wesley uh maybe with some ideas
of bringing knight over to e6 but for
the moment not really the knight is uh
perfectly fine here if needed maybe we
can shift it over to
the d6 square maybe we're going to put
it on e4 maybe the other knight is
coming to e4 all depends on what black
plays so bishop the h6 going after the
knight and queen to d2 now defending the
knight we have queen to d7 uh putting
pressure on the h3 pawn and here king
the h1 asking black are you maybe
interested in this um nice h3 pawn but
it's not something that you want to grab
then rook to g1 is coming and you are
only helping white develop and attack
your king so here black has a brilliant
brilliant idea and that is bishop
capture sun g5 bishop captures on g5 and
now comes the brilliant idea that was
not played in the game so i'm not going
to tell you what was played in the game
rather feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the absolute best moved
well
win the game for black really because
this would be very very difficult to
parry while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this idea
because this is one of the hardest moves
that we've had on a pause the video
moment and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is ponte h6
that's the move and it's really really
an incredible one now that you see it of
course you see after bishop captures an
h6 we're going to play queen to h7 and
then white is in trouble because you
can't really move the bishop you can't
allow queen captures an h3 with check so
you could move the bishop at the h4
that's not really all that impressive
then we capture on h3 and the game
continues but the bishop will not be
so nicely placed on h4 the real trick is
what happens if bishop to e3
here the thing is knight captures on c4
now we give up the knight we attack the
bishop and the queen here and after
bishop captures knight on c4 then comes
bishop to d3 i mean absolute madness
giving up the bishop as well the bishop
of course cannot be captured now queen
captures an h3 is a threat and if we
play something like bishop captures then
white will get checkmated king g1 queen
g4 check we're going to move the king
wherever and now rook f3
white will get checkmated very soon so
instead after bishop to d3 white will
have to play something like king g2
guard the h3 phone but still it's not
all that much first we're going to
capture the bishop on c4 and now after
the rook moves let's say rook to g1 now
we play knight to e7 and we prepared to
pile up on the on the white king so this
is an incredible
uh incredible line and it would be it
would be well simply outstanding if if i
mean found this for example king h2 rook
f3 is coming going after the h3 pawn
white has to defend this rook g3 then
queen f5 we prepared to bring the other
rook into the game rotate the g1 but it
just worked the g8 and all trades of
course favor black there's not much for
white to look forward to here so
uh if this was possible however it's a
rapid game of course you can't waste
all this much time calculating all of
the all of the bishops retreats and
finding all the these nights nice ideas
like sacrificing the night and then
trying to give up the bishop i mean
absolute madness so bishop captures an
h3 was played which is not a bad move it
just allows wesley to bounce back in the
game rook to g1
uh rook captures on f2 and now queen e3
we have rook a to f8 black is getting a
lot of development in and a lot of moves
aimed at attacking the white king
knight the e for now attacking the rook
and now knight captures on c4 so
attacking the queen giving up
the knight but we are really winning the
f3 square for our rook so here bishop
captures on c4 has to be played now rook
2 to f3 attacks the queen and now bishop
to f6 with check uh here bishop to f6
check is not the most precise way the
most precise way is bishop to b5 i will
just show it because i know you guys
will enjoy it uh the point is uh we want
to remove uh uh well the queen from d7
we do not want the queen guarding the
bishop here and now after the queen
captures now we play wesley's idea
bishop to f6 check rook captures bishop
knight captures and after knight
captures we pick up the uh the bishop on
h3 and now uh it's it's it's perfectly
fine so instead after rook two to f3
bishop to f6 check right away was played
now comes rook captures on f6 knight
captures and now rook captures on f6 we
have rook to g3 now
uh preparing to pick up the bishop
bishop to g4 and now rook to f1 offering
a trade of rooks which i mean goes for
we have rook captures on f1 bishop
captures on f1 and now knight to f6 also
maybe instead of knight to f6 h5 is is
not a bad idea just keeping that rook
here on g3 now the bishop is very very
strong here but i mean has a different
plan he plays knight to f6 it goes after
the d5 pawn also adds more defense to
the bishop here king g1
and now queen to f5 with queen to h6 by
wesley
and now knight to e4 going after the
rook and g3 we have rooked also queen to
f2 is a terrible threat so we have to
prevent this we have rook to g2 now
comes queen to f6 offering a queen trade
and uh wesley goes for it queen captures
knight captures and now we have this end
game uh where uh i mean uh is down the
exchange but he is up three pawns so
three points for the exchange that's
definitely a good deal
rook to g3 wesley will try to go after
those queen side pawns and now just h5
we have rook to a3 a6 rook to b3 in the
now b5 uh rook to a3 going after the a6
pawn and here i mean just played bishop
to c8 and if you look at the position
now uh black is up three pawns yes the
white is up the exchange but three pawns
i mean white is really without a move
and now we're just gonna bring the black
king into the game bring the knight into
the game uh win the win the d5 pawn and
that's just it uh but there is a problem
here there is one move that wesley can
play in order not to lose the game so
once again feel free to pause the video
and try to find this move for wesley
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
bishop is on the same rank as the king
and imagine if the rook was here then
you would win the bishop so uh having
that in mind uh congratulations to
everyone who found bishop capture sun b5
as this is the only move that doesn't
lose the game for wesley a captures on
b5 of course now comes rook to a8 we are
picking up this bishop king to g7 and
now rook captures on c8 and now
okay it's still uh
pretty good for black but it's it's much
much easier for white because now white
has a
well a very strong weapon that he can
utilize and that of course is the soon
to be passed a pawn so king f7 now comes
rook to b8 attacking the pawn b4 and now
pawn to a4 we've created a pass pawn b
captures on a3 alpha and b captures on
a3 and now knight captures on d5 so
again black is up three pawns but the
past a pawn could be uh could be very
very dangerous so wesley starts pushing
it king to e7 a5 now comes knight to b4
guarding that a6 square and rook to b6
by wesley we have kinked the d7 and here
wesley pushed the pawn to a6 and now uh
the only way to uh to play this with
black is to capture the pawn you capture
the pawn and uh then you then you try to
to fight this out real capture so you're
gonna push c4 maybe try and get those
spawns down the board it's not going to
be easy and it's uh well it it should be
a draw but with a low a low time on the
clock it's never certain and wesley had
plenty of time on the clock he had some
four minutes i think whereas i mean it
was already down to 10 seconds and he
played knight to d5 knight the c6 is
still fine because you can always
capture the pawn on a7 but after knight
to d5 uh there's a problem wesley just
played rook to b8 and he was in this
position animal 47 that amin tabatabai
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the problem is now
there's no way to give up the knight for
the pawn if you try king to c7 you
attack the rook we just play a7 and now
if knight to b6 hoping to pick up the
queen once you promote uh white will of
course just capture the knight king
capture so we bring a queen into the
game and another thing after rook to b8
uh for example knight to c7 can be
played but now we just play a7 and after
king to c6 or whatever move you make if
you don't move the king of course then
we're just gonna pin the knight and then
after the king moves we're gonna capture
the knight and then promote our pawn to
a queen if king to c6 then we up in the
knight this way uh we just uh play rook
to c8 and then after king b7 going after
the phone we captured the knight king
capture spawn promotes the queen and
that's it uh so it seems like there
always will be a way to give up the
knight for
uh for this pawn but after allowing
wesley to to move the rook like this
there simply wasn't uh wasn't any way
that
amin could do this so the knight
belonged with iron c5 or you should have
captured upon right away but this way
uh incredible so it's a really really uh
beautiful game much of this would not
happen if it wasn't a rapid time form
but but that's why we enjoy rapid so
much uh but this moment after uh here
after this kink the h1 was played king
to h1 is a move that doesn't work for
wesley because i mean played it
correctly and then he missed the h6 idea
but it's so beautiful that i thought
that uh you know regardless of how the
the game went from here i thought you
guys will enjoy the game just uh you
know because of this h6 idea that that
was missed as you know they say most of
the times the the greatest part of a
chess game isn't actually shown on the
board
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoy it uh enjoyed it today we are
starting the finals with the soul vs
hikaru nakamura we'll see how it goes so
hope you will enjoy that as well i would
like to thank openc smokey doula openc
smokey duel richard mckevin
customches.com and openc night at the
opera chess songs for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
grand prix and as usual checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day